[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires le 11 mai
prochain sera sans doute une date
mémorable pour nous tous
la france va commencer le déconfinement
les français se posent de nombreuses
questions sur leur sécurité sanitaire
notamment vous le savez concernant les
transports publics
alors quels gestes barrière à appliquer
comment désinfecter la métropole de
bordeaux et les transports de bordeaux
métropole ont fait une démonstration
dans une rame de tramway type les
équipes de télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest
en gironde on assister à cette
démonstration regarder avec la crise du
coc vider le confinement la
fréquentation du réseau de transports en
commun de l'agglomération s'est effondré
rien d'étonnant à cela
illustration de ce constat durant cette
période les ventes de type de transport
certains jours ou moins péniblement les
500 euros de recettes contre 150 me
quotidiennement en moyenne avant la
crise du coc vide
le défi pour les opérateurs du réseau
tbm et donc d'attirer à nouveau des
usagers dans les tramways et les bus dès
le 11 mai prochain
mais pour cela il faut restaurer d'une
certaine manière leur confiance est
entachée aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faudrait aller chez les gens sont
méfiants ils se croient qu'ils sont le
mieux protégés dans leur voiture ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas d'ailleurs
parce que quelquefois la climatisation
le filtre comme ça il ya des choses qui
sont à regarder c'est éviter que le 11
mai au matin on est des voitures à
l'embouteillage globale dans bordeaux
comme vous pouvez le connaître les
quelques semaines et qu'on s'est habitué
finalement ne pas les connaître depuis
depuis quelques jours et parmi les
mesures fortes annoncé l'utilisation des
transports en commun sur l'agglomération
sera gratuite durant tout le mois de mai
à l'heure actuelle seulement un tiers
des bus et des tramways circulent sur le
réseau dès lundi cette capacité devrait
atteindre 70% 90% le 25 mai prochain
le retour à la normale quand à lui est
prévu pour la mi juin dans les bus et
les trams les usagers ne pourront
utiliser qu'un siège sur deux le port du
masque sera obligatoire dans les
véhicules mais aussi dans les stations
ils pourront d'ailleurs être achetés
dans les agences tbm des équipes
veillons au respect des gestes-barrières
cher il va falloir
être pragmatique et savoir vivre presque
au jour le jour
adapté rassurer aussi et on espère
évidemment que aussi rapidement que
possible la clientèle reviendra du gel
hydroalcoolique sera disponible dans les
principaux pôles d'échangé du réseau une
dizaine de rames de tramway une
vingtaine de puces seront équipées de
distributeurs de gel
une attention particulière sera apportée
au nettoyage quotidien des stations des
distributeurs de titres de transport des
bus et des rames du tramway avant la
crise du coville le réseau de tv m
transportait cinq cent cinquante mille
voyageurs par jour
ces opérateurs espèrent atteindre
rapidement une moyenne de 150 mille le
plus rapidement possible voilà près la
problématique dans les transports les
parents d'élèves se pose aussi beaucoup
de questions
les jeunes enfants vont donc retourner
progressivement en classe et cela
suscite de nombreux débats à travers les
communes de france nos confrères du site
actu point fr vous explique dans cet
article
une journée type dans les établissements
scolaires nettoyage des classes cantine
nombre d'élèves toutes les réponses que
vous vous posez sont indiquées sur le
site d'actu point fr nos partenaires
dans ce grand jt des territoires une
autre question commence à agiter les
français où vont ils pouvoir passer
leurs vacances d'été est bien le
président a déclaré qu'une réponse sera
donnée au mois de juin alors que la
filière du tourisme
vous le savez est en berne depuis le
début de cette crise du coc vite 19
l'accès aux plages encore interdit pour
l'instant pourra-t-il avoir lieu
problématique importante et la polémique
enfle comme le montre ce reportage de
nos confrères de via occitanie regarder
et si l'accès à la plage était autorisée
uniquement pour la pratique sportive dès
le 11 mai je pense comme pourrait
peut-être maintenant envisager aussi
tout ce qui est plein de shawa tout ce
qui est clippers toutes ses chances de
la cua je crois que c'est ça peut ça
peut ça peut aussi se faire sur le
problème c'est c'est celle à bruxelles
demande des gens sur la plage
c'est cet auteur se dé confiné avec
intelligence c'est ce que réclament des
élus bretons à l'initiative de la
pétition hashtag rendez-nous à la mer le
texte propose un accès résonné aux
plages uniquement pour le sport est
rapidement le texte a fait écho aux élus
d'occitanie de saint-cyprien dans les
pyrénées-orientales à la grande motte
dans l'hérault les communes du littoral
vivent essentiellement du tourisme
ouverture des plages des landes mais oui
mais à l'australienne c'est une plage
dynamique c'est à dire c'est une plage
où on n'est pas statique sur une
serviette une ville de bagnères sans
plage c'est comme une voiture sans
moteur
est ce que nous demandons c'est que dans
un premier temps dans le cadre de ce
déconfinement et bien la pratique des
activités nautiques puissent reprendre
du côté des professionnels du nautisme
on attend le feu vert de l'état
c'est-à-dire l'autorisation de naviguer
le protocole d'hygiène est déjà bien
rodé locales et de réservation nous
permet d'espacer accueil des clients sur
le sur le site ensuite gestes-barrières
bien évidemment c'est à dire sens de
circulation à l'arrivée et ensuite au
départ on va mélanger les entrants et
les sortants et les gens donc accèdent
directement leur embarcation
donc l'espace est suffisant ensuite le
départ se fait en mer donc forcément
distanciation social ça va être une
année un peu spéciale on va être obligé
de réduire un peu les effectifs
légèrement donc et puis embauché les
personnes n'est plus technique
c'est-à-dire les moniteurs diplômés qui
permette d'encadrer les activités après
pour toutes ces petites mains ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué de les garder à
cette année on va être sûr de moi grand
maximum en attendant un signe du
gouvernement les plages restent fermés
au public jusqu'au 1er juin
voilà tout à fait autre chose maintenant
vous le savez le président de la
république annoncé des aides au monde de
la culture qui souffrent dans cette
période de covin 19 les salles de cinéma
sont toutes fermées elles le resteront
même après le 11 mai certains
exploitants conserve pourtant un esprit
solidaire vous allez le voir comme h
avant en isère le directeur du cinéma a
décidé de donner tout son stock de
produits périssables
c'est à dire les glaces les pop corn et
cacahuètes tout ce que vous consommez
dans le cinéma
regardez le reportage de nos confrères
de télé grenoble sur place c'est un
silence de cathédrale qui règne dans le
pathé chavant les warner d'habitude
rempli de pop corn sont désormais vides
et le mur à bonbons est lui aussi fermé
voilà un mois et demi que le cinéma a
cessé son activité comme l'ensemble des
complexes cinématographiques de france
pour autant ici tout n'est pas
totalement à l'arrêt et on s'est
organisé également pour ce
joindre différentes opérations solidaire
lancée dans le pays la première
initiative a été du pâté chirol ils ont
donné leurs stocks donc notamment les
stocks qui vont jusqu'à la fin du mois
de mai aux hôpitaux de grenoble nous on
a du coup on a pris la décision de
plutôt donner à la banque alimentaire
voilà alors après là on donne nos stocks
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai on refera
des donations le mois prochain
car si le déconfinement démarre pour une
majorité dans droit et de commerce le 11
mai prochain
les complexes cinématographiques à
l'image des restaurants ou des bars
devront eux toujours restés fermés et si
cette période délicate est encore amené
à durer les incertitudes autour de
l'activité à venir durant l'été sont
elles aussi bien nombreuses même quand
les consignes gouvernementales seront
prises nous on sait pas ni comment ni
quand on va reprendre parce que c'est
vrai que l'exploitation
cinématographique est liée aux
distributeurs de films et donc nous on
va être liée aussi à la distribution de
films c'est à dire savoir quel film on
va pouvoir avoir peut-être qu'on va
organiser des festivals pour reprendre
parce qu'on aura peut-être pas de film à
exploiter et le problème est aussi là
car si le cinéma est autorisé à ouvrir
de nouveau ses portes au grand public
cet été il a vu bon nombre de ses films
être reporté james bond ce printemps
wonder woman en juin mulan et top gun en
juillet autant de films décalés à des
dates différentes
une chose est sûre l'horizon est encore
loin d'être dégagé pour l'industrie du
cinéma
voilà sans attendre le 11 mai il faut se
protéger avec le port du masque si vous
avez à sortir si vous n'avez pas de
masque ci peut arriver vous l'avez
compris
regardez ce reportage qui va suivre et
cet élan de formidable générosité à issy
les moulineaux en ile de france où des
habitants se succèdent sur des
imprimantes 3d pour réaliser des vizirs
de protection lavables et réutilisables
l'objectif est bien c'est sans visière
par jour destiné en premier lieu aux
soignants au personnel des ehpad et aux
commerçants autorisé e à travailler
le reportage est signée olivier un état
devient grand paris
de ces imprimantes 3d sortent tous les
jours 80 vizir de protection pour les
soignants et personnels des ehpad en
vitesse de croisière
ce seront deux cent trente vizir par
jour des habitants de la ville
d'issy-les-moulineaux se sont portés
volontaires pour fabriquer ces
équipements ils sont formés et encadrés
par des étudiants de l'école
d'ingénieurs de la ville une grande
mobilisation
on accueille tout type de personnes
aussi bien des élèves de mon école qui
ont été volontaires aussi bien des gens
qui font partie d'une association de
bénévoles d'issy les moulineaux ou que
je forme tout type de personne qui est
aussi bien rencontrer des parents des
jeunes étudiants un peu de tout âge qui
ont été volontaires pour nous aider à ce
projet des imprimantes 3d contre le coc
vie de 19 des machines à coudre aussi
une quarantaine de couturières se sont
mobilisés pour fabriquer des sur blues
qui manque cruellement soignant une
action solidaire très encadrée on a mis
en place tout un processus assez
rigoureux parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'envoyer du tissu chez des couturières
qu'ils soient contaminés et encore moins
d'envoyer du tissu contaminée dans les
ehpad et des hôpitaux
voilà mais elle travaille d'arrache-pied
pour constituer sied / blues / blues
jetables ou réutilisables à destination
donc des hôpitaux des ehpad
une fois les sur blues et vizir réaliser
un autre réseau de bénévoles s'activent
les chauffeurs livreurs
car il s'agit maintenant de passer à la
distribution 200 habitants sont
mobilisés chaque jour à issy les
moulineaux contre le coc vite 19
voilà après l'ile-de-france direction
l'aube à présent où les syndicats et les
professionnels du monde agricole ont
lancé un appel via le site internet des
bras pour ton assiette
celui ci a pour but de recruter des
saisonniers vous allez le voir
et cet appel à la mobilisation a été
très entendus à assen sierre et à ali
baudière ce sont des productrices
d'aspect rj qui ont pu facilement
recruter des volontaires ces
candidatures spontanées sont parfois
motivée par des nécessités financières
vous vous en doutez dû au chômage
partiel ou à l'inactivité totale de
certaines filières et de certaines
entreprises comme le montre ce reportage
de nos confrères de canal 32 à 3
regarder des bras pour mon assiette
ce site permet de mettre en contact des
agriculteurs aux viticulteurs en manque
de main d'oeuvre avec des personnes
prêtes à s'investir ponctuellement à
hollywood hier armelle très inquiète au
début du confinement et à un mois et
demi je savais pas du tout ce qu'on
allait faire donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait que entière notre chambre a pu
recruter sans difficulté se tenait
trouver de la main d'oeuvre c'est
compliqué et cette année pour la
première fois on a eu beaucoup de
candidatures spontanées
corinne a été sélectionné originaire de
saint julien les villas
elle effectue un trajet de 40 km pour
venir cueillir des asperges au lieu de
rester à la maison à rien faire et bien
autant et débats les agriculteurs
à sens hier en raison du coronavirus
l'équipe polonaise parfaitement rodé
depuis dix ans n'est pas venu du coup
les gérants de recruter localement
les candidatures sont nombreuses
étudiants retraités est majoritairement
des personnes en chômage partiel ou dont
l'activité professionnelle est
interrompue je suis restauratrice à
creney près troyes la côte et j'ai
trouvé un peu de travail
c'est quand on travaille dans la
restauration on rentre élargi bas au
moins déjà nourrir et nourrir déjà la
survie malheureusement ce n'est pas avec
cela que je vais sauver tank intérim en
fait le chômage partiel je les touche et
jusqu'à la fin de ma mission qui étaient
31 mars
en revanche depuis le 31 mars rien du
tout donc je rencontrais du monde aussi
peut-être bien sûr c'est physique
absolument c'est dur maintenant j'ai 58
ans et je le troisième pour remonter
celui là il y tue asperges bientôt
fraises ses cueillettes à nécessite dans
la main d'oeuvre jusqu'à juin bien au
delà du début du déconfinement nous
avons déjà une personne qui retravaille
donc on a dû recruter une personne est
donc là à partir du 11 mai ben on est un
petit peu dans l'expectative dans le
sens où on ne sait pas actuellement 6 et
tout le monde va reprendre ou pas parce
que nos cueilleurs ne sont pas
aujourd'hui fixés sur leur sort
sur le site weezy forme des postes
restent à pourvoir dans le département
de l'aube
restons dans le domaine agricole ou la
crise n'a pas eu que des effets négatifs
vous allez voir elle a permis notamment
à un regain d'activité pour certains
producteurs locaux
c'est notamment le cas dans le bassin
chambérien au lycée agricole reynac déjà
habitué à vendre de nombreux produits
issus de ces producteurs partenaires
la demande a plus que doublé depuis le
début du confinement c'est un reportage
dans ce lycée agricole signé d'emmanuel
jo pour la chaîne 8 mont blanc regard
des fromages bières légumes ou encore
fleurs tous ces produits sont en vente
au lycée agricole de la motte-servolex
une démarche qui ne date pas d'hier mais
qui a connu un vrai boom ces dernières
semaines
cela grâce à une curieuse conjoncture
générées par la crise sanitaire
planétaire pour les onze producteurs qui
travaillent avec nous dans le cadre d'un
ingénieux en groupement d'intérêt
économique
certains voyaient leur clientèle faveur
leur leurs produits ont depuis pu
s'écouler parce que les marchés fermés
et donc ça a été une opportunité pour
nous de développer cette vente avec un
nombre important de clients en plus et
un panier moyen également mais plus
important les gens venaient est
commandée pour des sommes qu'ils étaient
deux trois quatre fois plus par rapport
à d'habitude
en effet depuis des années déjà le lycée
reina qui ces producteurs assurent de 60
à 80 commandes hebdomadaire
mais avec le confinement c'est désormais
plus de 200 demandes qu'il faut traiter
chaque semaine un nouveau public qui
connaissait la structure sans jamais
oser faire le pas au niveau des clients
on a pas mal qui ont qui sont arrivées
récemment et
certains me disant on habite juste à
côté du lycée mc et on en avait entendu
parler mais on n'est jamais venu et
c'est l'occasion ils ont profité du
confinement pour regarder les
producteurs locaux et on a fait beaucoup
de clients qui sont juste les voisins du
lycée mais qui n'étaient jamais venus
jusqu'à plus généralement nombreux sont
les producteurs locaux qui observe
aujourd'hui une hausse de leur carnet de
commandes malgré l'annulation de
nombreux points de vente
une tendance également observée sur le
nouveau site de la collectivité dédié
aux commerces de proximité et qui
cartographient tous les exploitants du
territoire seul chanceux toute façon
deux des grands enseignements que de
cette crise sanitaire nous nous propose
que 2 que d'avoir un une confiance dans
la chaîne de distribution des produits
locaux les savoir-faire la garantie de
produits sains de produits sans ogm bio
autant que possible et voilà de façon à
que ça contribue à notre santé
faire grandir nos enfants dans de bonnes
conditions une évolution également
synonyme de plus de travail pour de
nombreux producteurs mais qui préfère
relativiser en espérant que l'attrait
des bonnes choses ne soient pas qu'un
effet de mode
alors beaucoup de secteurs sont très
impactées par cette crise du coc vie de
19 notamment celui des travaux publics
et de la construction les entreprises
s'y organise et reprennent peu à peu
leur activité tout en assurant la
sécurité de leurs salariés leurs clients
exemple avec ce reportage dans une
société à saint cyr l'école dans les
yvelines signé de nicolas landry et de
patrick jacques de dixmude pour tv 78
nos partenaires sur place
peinture et pose de parquet dans cet
appartement un chantier de reprise pour
khaled salariés au sein de cette société
spécialisée dans le revêtement en arrêt
depuis le 17 mars l'entreprise a relancé
son activité depuis le lundi 27 avril
on a deux en or tout ce qu'il faut qu'on
comme le démasquer les gir usuels
entravant dispense un mètre à un mètre
et demi entre les deux réorganisations
du planning replanification de chantier
prévue ultérieurement et équipements
sanitaires pour ses salariés le
dirigeant de cette entreprise du
bâtiment à préparer la reprise
on a repris des chantiers qu'on avait
laissé un peu en stand by
d'autres pas parce qu'on n'a pas
l'accord de nos clients pour pouvoir les
reprendre ces chantiers là tant que la
date de déconfinement est pas prononcée
en l'occurrence on a on doit compter sur
la bonne volonté de nos clients et de
nos salariés aussi c'était important
pour des questions de trésorerie ni plus
ni moins parce que ça devenait compliqué
pour nous à gérer même si on a essayé de
bénéficier des dispositifs de l'état on
a on avait une trésorerie qui nous
permettait quand on a quand on a su
qu'on allait devoir fermer on avait une
trésorerie qui nous permettait grosso
modo de tenir un brin peu plus d'un mois
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire sa
société a obtenu le chômage partiel pour
ses salariés et bénéficier d'un prêt
garanti par l'état pour préparer la
reprise julien blanchard a organisé une
réunion avec ses 15 employés
l'objet de la réunion d'hier c'était de
de les former entre guillemets de les
sensibiliser sur les gestes barrières et
la sécurité qui va falloir mettre encore
plus en oeuvre que d'habitude sur les
chantiers à venir
actuellement 40 % de son effectif a
repris une activité tous les
collaborateurs devraient revenir au
travail à partir du 11 mai autre exemple
cette fois en bretagne où l'on se rend
maintenant la région produit 40% du
cidre consommée en france et dans les
vergers breton et bien les conditions de
floraison qui s'annonçait c'était des
conditions formidables pour cette saison
2020 sans compter sur cette liste du
comité 19 la filière cidricole comme on
l'appelle subi et les effets du
confinement et tire la sonnette d'alarmé
regardez ce reportage de karine
chevrollier de tb sud en bretagne dans
cette exploitation quarante à cinquante
mille litres de cidre sont produits
chaque année
cafés hôtels restaurants et vente
directe représente plus de 50% du
chiffre d'affaires
nous sommes dans le pays d'auray l'un
des premiers kloster identifié covit
10,9 et soumis au confinement depuis
début mars
je ne vois plus personne à la cidrerie
rassure mars on est à moins 50 % et sur
avril c'est 70% d'hommes et le mois de
mai ne s'annonce pas meilleur commandes
annulées trésorerie décalé ce producteur
de cidre subi la crise sanitaire de
plein fouet le développement de la vente
à emporter n'a évidemment pas permis de
compenser la fermeture des cafés hôtels
restaurants
cette formule a un avenir de façon plus
globale sur la filière agricole mais ce
n'est pas ça qui va me rattraper toutes
les ventes perdues par ailleurs et sur
la partie restauration le temps que ça
reparte sera pas avant je pense mi
juillet parce que eux aussi ont des
stocks qui vont devoir écouler la
question des stocks pose problème
comment écouler la future récolte pour
faire face à cette situation l'union
nationale cidricole de man notamment le
retrait des volumes
nous avons demandé si des mesures de
retrait d'un certain volume de signer à
la fin d'un certain volume de fruits de
manière à pouvoir les orienter vers la
production d'alcool industriels
notamment ont peut-être une destination
de la fabrication de gel hydro
alcoolique ou vers la méthanisation ça
impacte de sortir mes bouteilles de les
vider
de voir ce que j'en fais de dix mille
litres en q c'est assez facile à gérer
quand vous avez l'équivalent en
bouteille la perte est double vous allez
mettre plus de temps à vider vos
bouteilles qu'ils allaient remplir parce
que la partie remplissage est mécanisé
la partie pour les vider ne l'est pas si
ça eu une bouteille à vide et il faut
compter une semaine à la main tout ça
l'appel a été lancé au gouvernement
l'urgence est temps pour la profession
d'éviter l'arrachage des pommiers
ils en ont bien besoin une bonne idée
pour les parents maintenant surtout ceux
qui font l'école à la maison les
initiatives d'animation participative
fleurissent un peu partout sur la toile
sur les réseaux vous les avez vus
pourquoi pas réviser sa grammaire son
orthographe et bien un maire d'un petit
village vosgien par ailleurs directeur
d'école a eu l'idée de proposer une
dictée en live deux fois par semaine
pour ses élèves dans un premier temps
mais désormais bien au-delà
regardez ce reportage de nos confrères
de via vosges à ben de l'avs line depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est devenu un
rendez vous attendu deux fois par
semaine depuis son salon le maire de
bandol aveline et directeur d'école à
saint-dié-des-vosges donne rendez vous
sur facebook pour une dictée mais au
début l'idée c'était vraiment juste pour
mes élèves de l'école de la baule de
saint dié et l'idée est venue a fait son
chemin tiens pourquoi pas finalement la
faire en grand public d'où l'idée de
dicter familiale chaque mercredi et
dimanche
rendez vous est donné à 18h30 discuter
dès la toute première connexion donc un
dimanche de début avril il ya eu plus de
120 participants 120 connectés donc en
multipliant par deux ou trois ou peut
être quatre membres de chaque famille
savait tout de suite une salle des fêtes
bien bien remplie en plus des élèves de
cm une petite communauté s'est formé
habitants paris-tours la réunion et bien
sûr les vosges prenons au jeu entre
autres le député gérard cherpion ou le
premier adjoint au maire d'epinal
patrick nardin d'édicter variés et les
personnaliser les textes de son
moi je me creuse un peu la tête la lutte
est numéro 1 a porté sur la vie de la
forêt on a eu une dictée et le dimanche
de pâques s'appelait les jours heureux
qui était à la fois une poésie
il ya une dictée qui était donc des
citations d'hommes célèbres bonne humeur
amusement son maître mot pas de piège
mais un moyen de réviser qui a
enthousiasmé cette famille l'avelinois
zh qui invite ainsi leur mère dans leur
salon on a quasiment fait toute les
dictées depuis le départ on en a
peut-être loupé une mais oui c'est
devenu un rendez vous à ne pas manquer
ce soir ça s'est passé très bien enfin
je pense et je pense que c'est ça permet
de s'améliorer
des mots comme ça qu'ils t'ont poser des
problèmes utiliser le savait mais
j'avais famille des ailes on oublie un
je pense qu'on n'oublie pas mal de
choses depuis décolle donc forcément il
ya des mots qui sont un peu plus
compliquées que d'autres d'autres qu'on
a plus l'habitude
donc forcément fait des photos vous est
arrivé de faire beaucoup de fautes
ouais je veux pas dire trop fort la
dernière dictée est prévu le 10 mai à la
veille du déconfinement méprise au jeu
certains espèrent que ce rendez-vous
perdurera à un autre rythme tout au long
de l'année
voilà un peu de détente et de sport pour
terminer ce grand jt des territoires
direction la sarthe maintenant avec un
marathon pas comme les autres cinquante
et une famille ont couru les fameux 42
kilomètres carrés en simultané dans
quelques mètres carrés cela peut sembler
long sauf bien sûr quand c'est en
famille et dans la bonne humeur comme
vous allez le voir le tout au profit du
centre hospitalier du mans
diane le moisson de via lmtv sarthe a
couru à leurs côtés caméra au poing
regarder
dans la famille genou c'est 1688 our
qu'il faut accomplir le parcours ne fait
que 25 mètres mais cette en famille et
déguisée que l'on s'y mêlent à tous les
détours en cash que ça
[Musique]
derniers kilomètres l'idée partie d'un
petit délire entre nous en fait on avait
des échéances de prévu au niveau sportif
et nous devions organiser un trail à
clermont créans au mois d'avril avec la
situation actuelle bah voilà on est tous
un peu frustré donc on s'est lancé le
petit défi de faire un marathon dans
notre jardin à l'appui de fil en
aiguille principe a plu ça devait être
individuel c'est devenu familiale et
puis des gens en ont entendu parler au
nom des six plus le faire et donc on a
créé un événement qui fait que ben
aujourd'hui on est à quasiment 70
familles qui vont faire un marathon
aujourd'hui dans leur jardin terminer
une heure cinquante et un jardin lire
une et ça c'est fait on a besoin de
tendre sa fille des plus petits tours
donc ça fixe des plus petits objectifs
on n'a pas l'impression de ne pas voir
le bout
il ya une différence vraiment quand on
fait un vrai marathon où on n'en voit
pas le bout et puis s'il ya un moment
s'arrête on est bloqués faut absolument
repartir alors que là on est chez soi on
allait boire des coups envoyé des
messages aux copains
nos classes étaient super puis avec le
tableau à tous ensemble moi j'ai trouvé
que c'était hyper simple branchement
puis par les voisins sur leurs balcons
aussi on est franchement
l'événement s'est déroulé au profit du
centre hospitalier du mans 5 euros par
marathon terminé sont reversés par
l'association en plus des dons libres
fait par lille participants 51 marathons
sont validées la somme de 1200 46 euros
a été collecté voit la fin du grand jt
des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivis évidemment bon courage à tous
lors de cette semaine de déconfinement
qui arrive et puis nous on se retrouve
sur l'ensemble des télévisions
régionales et locales de france ainsi
que sur tv5 monde pour une prochaine
édition
au revoir à tous et faites attention à
vous au revoir
[Musique]